one of the books you wrote the most
recent one called false alarm how
climate change Panic costs us trillions
hurts the poor and fails to fix the
planet
good title by the way very intense makes
me want to read it what is likely the
worst effect of climate change first let
me just uh my my editor actually hated
the subtitle because it gives away the
whole book basically it tells you what
the book tries to make I I think you
know that's exactly what it should be
it's about getting this conversation out
in the in in the public sphere so the
worst thing that climate change can do
is like the worst thing that anything
can do is that it wipes out everything
and we all die so it's it's not like you
know if you're just looking for worst
case outcomes uh you know anything can
get to the worst case outcome
um imagine if we uh suggest what's the
worst thing that could happen from HIV
it breaks down of a one or more African
States because we don't fix it and then
you get sort of uh biological warfare
and terrorism throwing that in the mix
and then you get someone who makes a
virus and kills the whole world you know
you can make worst case scenarios for
everything well let's just call it I get
the point and sorry for an interruption
and and I appreciate worst case analysis
because I'm I am fundamental computer
scientist and that was the thing that
defined the discipline of the to measure
the quality of the algorithm you measure
what is its worth worst case performance
that's the Big O notation that's how you
discuss algorithms what is the worst
possible thing uh in terms of
performance this thing can do but for
climate change let's even go crazy what
is exactly the worst case scenario for
climate change because uh
I have to be honest and say I haven't
really paid it deep attention I just
have a lot of colleagues who think about
climate and so on and there's a kind of
in the alarmism there was a sense why
this is this is a very serious problem
and then the sentence would never finish
what exactly is the problem well the
extinction of the human species okay
with a virus I understand how that can
possibly happen what is the mechanism by
which the human species becomes extinct
because of climate change I'm not sure I
would want to be able to argue that
because it really requires you to have
sort of very very extreme parameter
choices all down the line and so it's
more you know it's this kind of idea
that we that we hit some of these
unexpected uh outcomes so for instance
uh the Western Arctic ice sheet melts
really really quickly it doesn't look
like that can happen really really
quickly but let's just you know say that
this could happen within 100 years or
something so we basically get what
um seven meters what is that 20 feet of
sea level rise uh that will be a real
challenge to a lot of places around the
world this would have you know
significant costs uh it's likely and you
know there's actually been a study
that's tried to estimate could we deal
with that and the this the short answer
is yes if you're fairly well off you
know if you're a Holland you can
definitely deal with it it's also likely
that most developing countries are going
to be much closer to Holland towards the
end of the century because they'll be
much richer so they can probably handle
it but it will be a real challenge may
ask a dumb question yeah what happens
when the sea level rises exactly what is
the painful aspect of that
it is that all of your current
infrastructure and a lot of coastal
cities around the world that are
literally built on you know Jakarta is a
good example that are literally built on
the uh just you know inches above the
sea level uh if if you then get a sea
level rise they'll rise say what would
uh 20 feet if that would be like a third
or a fourth of a of a foot every year
yeah I see no evidence that that's even
hold on a second let's we're not talking
about evidence not talking about worst
case analysis and algorithms and and so
so basically you would see your
infrastructure all all your stuff very
quickly being very very challenged and
you basically have to put up huge sea
walls or migrate out of that very
quickly well very quickly in 50 years or
something right so like I is that as a
human species
we're not able to respond to that kind
of course and and look again the point
here is then there's there's a lot of
other arguments and I I should just you
know put the disclaimer this is not what
I think is correct but you know you're
asking me what's the what's the worst
case outcome that you have uh uh so most
of global warming is really about that
we we're used to one way of doing things
so you know we we live in Jakarta
because it's right next to the Sea we're
used to the Sea being at this level uh
we grow our crops because we're used to
you know you grow a corn here you grow
wheat here because we're used to that
where the precipitation and the uh
temperature is the right for this kind
of crop if this changes and this is the
same thing with with you know with
houses if it gets colder if it gets
warmer it's suddenly uncomfortable
because you've built your house wrong so
our infrastructure will be wrong if the
world changes and that's what climate
change is at a large scale yes and so so
this is a problem in most of these
sentences but if you then sort of take
it to the extreme and say well imagine
that you're going to get a huge sea
level rise imagine that you're going to
get a very different sort of
precipitation for instance the the uh
what is it the rain season rain Monsoon
and and uh and and the Indian
subcontinent uh changes uh dramatically
that could affect a lot of Agriculture
and make it really hard to imagine that
you could feed India well there there
are these kinds of things where you can
imagine uh and then that this would be
very difficult to deal with and then if
you add all of it up you could possibly
get sort of a system collapse because
you know you just have too many problems
and it's impossible to model those kinds
of things so what I understand is the
sea level rise itself
isn't the destructive thing it's it's
the fact that it creates migration
patterns and human tension battle over
resources and since start to get these
these human things human conflict so the
big negative impact won't be necessary
from the fact they have to move your
house it's the fact that once you move
your house that means something else
down the line and it's a secondary
tertiary effects that can have
potentially towards military conflict
can have this destabilized entire
economies all that kind of stuff because
of the migration power is it possible to
model those kinds of things so there are
people who looked at this and and and
surprisingly again you know most people
will move within their country for a lot
of different reasons but you know mainly
language and and political structure you
have your money you have your
relationships there so it's not like
we're going to see these big moves you
know from uh from uh from the southern
Mexico and and Central America up to the
US or from Africa up to the EU that's
not predominantly because of climate
that's because there's a lot of you know
uh there's a lot of welfare opportunity
uh you can make your life much much
better you can become much more put
productive if you move into a richer
into a richer country so so yes there
are these issues again uh you you're
asking me for sort of what is it that
could really sort of break down the
world I think the the fundamental point
is to recognize that it's not like we
haven't dealt with huge challenges in
the past and we've dealt with them
really well so just one fun thing I I
encourage everyone to just look that up
on on Wikipedia the rising of Chicago
so in the uh in the 1850s Chicago is a
terribly uh uh uh dirty place and they
didn't have good sewers and so they
decided and we can't really make up all
my they decided to raise Chicago one to
two feet
and so they simply took one block at a
time they put like 50 000 Jacks
underneath a building and they would
just raise the building and then they'd
go on to the next building they race all
of Chicago one or two feet this is you
know almost 200 years ago of course we
will be able to deal with these things
I'm not saying it'd be it'll be fun or
that it'll be cheap of course we would
rather not have to deal with this but
we're a very inventive species and so
it's very unlikely that we'll not be
able to what about
covid pandemic just said hold my beer
uh the response of human civilization to
the covert pandemic
seems to have not
they didn't find the carjacks yeah she
seems to have not been as effective as I
would have hoped uh for uh as a human
that believes in the in the basic
competence of leadership and all that
kind of stuff it seems that given the
the covet pandemic luckily did not turn
out to be a pandemic that's that would
eradicate most of the human species
which is something you always have to
consider and worry about that I would
have hoped we would have less economic
impact and we would respond more
effectively and
um in terms of policy in terms of
socially medically all that kind of
stuff so if the if the cover pandemic
brought the world to its knees then what
does
a sea level rise so I think there's a
different kind of thing that happened in
the in the covet so politicians and a
lot of politicians I think made
certainly sub-optimal decisions but I
also find the fact that we actually
managed to get a vaccine in a year uh we
should not be uh you know sort of
unaware of the fact that yes we did a
lot of stupid stuff and a lot of people
were really really annoyed but
fundamentally we fixed this uh we could
have done it better and pretty I mean I
I uh rode through the covet pandemic in
southern Sweden uh so uh and yes we we
can have that whole conversation it was
certainly a much easier to live there
than than many other places but the
fundamental point was we actually fixed
it so yes we'll do and we'll do that
with climate we'll make a lot of bad
decisions and we'll waste a lot of money
like we do with all other problems but
it's are we going to fix this yeah can
you add on to that uh uncomfortable
discussion of what's the worst thing
that could possibly happen I'm not
worried about the sea level rise
component certainly not nearly as much
as the Heat and disruption of
Agriculture patterns and water supplies
and a lot of it relates to
again path dependency and history
farmers are the heroes of humanity all
through history because they're
incredibly adaptable
if you give them access to resources uh
in some cases it's just crop insurance
which is really basically still
impossible to get in big chunks of
Africa to get you through those hard
spots but but the heat issue is the one
that's most the most base basic element
related to global warming from CO2
buildup is uh hotter heat waves there's
still some lack of evidence of
the intensification but the duration and
and that's really matters for heat how
many days
seems to be very powerfully linked to
global warming and so how many people
die as a result of that is important so
we're talking about
maybe you can also educate me what's the
average projection for the next
100 years as the temperature rises at
two two degrees Celsius well yeah
although this gets us into the modeling
realm um you're you're assuming you have
to assume different emissions
possibilities
you have to assume we still don't know
the basic physics like how many clouds
form
in a warming climate and how that
relates to limiting warming there are
aspects of the warming the fundamental
warming question there's still deeply
uncertain but the debate is like two
three or four Celsius it's in that range
the thing is
all of those are bad for this is an
educational question sure it uh doesn't
seem like that much from a weather
perspective if you just turn up the AC
and so on in your own personal home but
it is from a Global Perspective a huge
impact on agriculture well yeah and and
getting back to sea level and Glaciers
the the melting point of ice is a is a
number yeah and so if you pass that
number things change start to change
what became known about Antarctica and
Greenland more is that it's ocean
temperature
the the sea water in and around and
under these ice sheets because it kind
of gets under parts of Antarctica is
what's driving the Dynamics that could
lead to more abrupt change more than air
temperature glaciers these big ice
sheets live or die based on
how much snow falls and how much ice
leaves every year and
I was up on the Greenland ice sheet
2004.
I've written about it forever since then
you know it's it's the same amount of
water that's in the Gulf of Mexico as if
you know God or some great force came
down and Flash flows the Gulf of Mexico
and plunked it up on land that's that's
the ice sheet it's a lot of water that's
23 feet if sea level rise if you but
we're not going to melt at all and the
pace at which that
erosion begins
and becomes sort of a runaway train
is still
not well understood
that changed from like a manageable
level of sea level rise from these ice
sheets to something that becomes truly
Unstoppable or that has these
discontinuities where you get a lot more
of a sudden isn't to me it's in the
realm of
what I've taken a calling known
unknowables like don't count on another
ipcc report magically including science
that says aha now we know it's going to
be five feet by 2100 because learning
there's a lot of negative learning in
science this may be true in your body of
science too
um there's a guy named Jeremy bassis
b-a-s-s-i-s
who wrote a paper about the this West
antic the the idea that you could get
this sudden cliff
breakdown of these ice shelves around
Antarctica leading to Rapid sea level
rise he did more modeling in physics and
it turns out that you end up with it's a
much more Progressive and self-limiting
phenomenon
but those papers don't get any attention
in the media because they're not scary
they're not scary and they're sort of
after the fact you know just this past
year there's been this cycle around uh
collapse the word collapse
and Antarctic Antarctic Ice um it
started uh actually several years ago
with the idea that this the West
Antarctic ice sheet is particularly
vulnerable
and some paper everyone's the science
Community like the birds we were talking
about flux to it and some high profile
papers are written
and then a deeper inquiry reveals that
you know it's more complicated than that
and we the journalists the media pundits
don't pay attention to that stuff
so and actually
which is why I've started to develop
kind of a dictionary like I call it
watch words like words to if you're out
there
you're you know you're just a public per
your person you want to know what's
really going on you hear these words
like collapse
in the context of ice what do you do
with that and so I've created
conversations around these words
geologists and Ice scientists use the
word collapse they're talking about a
centuries-long process
they're not talking about the World
Trade Center and
scientists would do well to be more
careful with words like that unless your
focus is what we're saying earlier
your idea that alarming people will
spur them to act then you use that word
carelessly uh can it can I just follow
up on the on the other point that you
said you know two three four degrees you
know that doesn't sound like much I can
just crank up the air conditioning I
think that sort of touches on a really
really important point that for most
rich people
much of climate change is not really
going to be all that impactful it still
will have an impact but fundamentally if
you're well off you can mitigate a lot
of these impacts and as a young
scientist at Carnegie Mellon Destiny
knock
she just was the lead author on a study
um
what poor and prosperous households do
in a heat wave when they have access to
air conditioning in a poor household
you wait they found through science
they delay turning on the air
conditioner four to seven degrees more
of heating before they start to use the
air conditioner and that create adverse
outcomes if you have an estimatic in the
house an old person you're you're
endangering endangering their lives and
that's just a little tiny microscopic
fractal example
this powerful real phenomenon that
there's a divide and vulnerability and
it's not just based on where you live
this is families in like Pittsburgh
we're not talking about you know
Botswana and
so that that divide and capacity to deal
with um environmental stress is
something you can really work on and it
gets hidden in all this talk of climate
crisis people and and that that's one of
the important parts is is both to say
look if seven billion people sorry eight
billion people will now have all
experienced this even though for each
one of them it's manageable it's still a
big problem because it's you know eight
billion people living through this and
the second edition eight billion yes and
and then it's uh it's the it's the point
of getting to realize it's very very
much about how do you help the world's
poor and that's very much about making
it more affordable uh yeah basically
getting them out of poverty and remember
getting out of poverty doesn't just mean
that they can now afford to air
condition themselves but they get better
they get better education they get
better opportunities they get you know
better lives in so many other ways and
then at the end of it it is it's not
just about making sure that we focus on
this one problem but it's recognizing
that these families and and have have
lots of different issues that they would
like us to focus on climb climate and
heat waves just being one of them so you
know it's sort of taking Progressive
steps back and realizing all right okay
this is a problem
not the end of the world and one tiny
little last example you mentioned
Jakarta at the beginning
it's really valuable to look around the
world of places that are sort of leading
indicator places
whether it's sea level rise or heat and
you could do that um Jakarta is sinking
like a foot a year literally a foot a
year it's some insane number
from withdrawing groundwater from gas
withdrawal from it's a Delta you know
it's sediment it's built on sediment I
wrote a piece aging ages ago the New
York Times calling it delta blues you
know I'm a musicians and and Jakarta so
what are they doing they're moving
they're moving the capital to another uh
area and so that says to me
there's a lot of plasticity too it's
it's a city that's going through this
that rate of sea level
of their relationship with the sea level
through syncing is way faster than
what's happening with global warming so
look there look to those kinds of places
and you can start to build a Tokyo had
the same thing in the 1930s so we're
also withdrawing a lot of water way too
fast uh and and so you know one of the
obvious things is maybe you should stop
withdrawing water so fast you know and
and again we seem to almost be intent on
finding the most politically correct way
to fix a problem or you know the most
the thing that sort of gets the most
clicks instead of the thing that
actually works the best uh so a lot of
these things are really you know not
rocket science solution